نعلم جميعًا أن اتباع نظام غذائي متوازن
وممارسة بعض أشكال الرياضة في
روتينك اليومي هما مفتاحان لنمط حياة صحي ،
لكن قد لا تكون هذه
العوامل الوحيدة للبقاء لائقًا ،
وجدت دراسة رصدية حديثة في مجلة
Lancet Public Health أن الأشخاص
الذين يعيشون  نصف ميل من صالة الألعاب الرياضية أو
أي منطقة ترفيهية تزن أقل من
أولئك الذين
لم يجدوا أبحاثًا أخرى أن المزيد من
الأحياء التي يمكن المشي فيها مرتبطة أيضًا
بفقدان الوزن ،
وهناك عامل آخر للبقاء لائقًا وهو تناول
الأطعمة الغنية بالتوابل ، تظهر الأبحاث وجود
مركب حيوي رئيسي موجود في أطعمة مثل
قد يلعب الفلفل الحار دورًا في التحكم في الوزن
بما في ذلك تقليل الشهية
وزيادة استخدام الدهون كوقود
وزيادة التمثيل الغذائي ،
كما وجدت دراسة سابقة أيضًا وجود صلة بين
معدلات السمنة المنخفضة والعيش في منطقة
مرتفعة يقترح الباحثون أن انخفاض
مستويات الأكسجين وزيادة متطلبات التمثيل الغذائي
في  ارتفاعات أعلى قد تقلل
الشهية سبب آخر للعيش في
المدينة دراسة مختلفة fou  وجد أن الأشخاص
الذين عاشوا في المناطق الحضرية التي يبلغ
عدد سكانها مليون نسمة أو أكثر كانوا
أقل عرضة للإصابة بالسمنة بشكل ملحوظ
مقارنة بأولئك الذين يعيشون في المناطق الريفية أو
المقاطعات الصغيرة بالمترو في
الدقيقة الصحية اليوم أنا كيم هاتشرسون
[موسيقى]